au passage on glane tél
bonjour les clous jacques elle vient de
lui messieurs derniers échappés
alain chabat gérante au nom se voit non
jean moulin
ok
comme éditeur et pascal quéré
pas prendre
oh
je trouve simplement cette émission un
peu confuse et j'espère que la semaine
prochaine on fera une émission en
présence de charlotte qui est donc la
fille de bruno gaccio et unisciel
dernier de charlotte alarmant dans le
besoin
oui on va voir justement alors ce soir
il n'y aura pas de par équipes ce sera
du chacun pour sa gueule dès le départ
l'eau
rebecca doit marquer les gagnants et la
sortie on verra c'est le grand champion
de ses huit années de blindness voilà
ayant animé ce grain test j'ai
effectivement nadine de rothschild à vos
yeux
voilà mes enfants tout le monde et je la
lis ne vais pas ouais mais thierry
attend comme quoi ça c'est très
important
j'ai ici la liste de ceux qui m'ont
demandé lâchement
c'est que je n'ai pas donné puisque huit
ans n'a jamais divulgué une seule
réponse c'est vrai sauf non aux familles
c'est la mer fred au vfb sa demande j'ai
demandé une ville encore c'est pas bien
avancé
e
hélas la déception va être immense je
sais que devant leur télévision il
pleure vrai laurent baffie et non
les couilles attention là c'est chacun
pour sa gueule dès le départ
y a pas d'équipé n'y a pas de potes
c'est l'ultra libéralisme caméra tiens
soufflage à berne âge dans le monde et
est pourquoi la ville m'a bien derrière
donc attention on est tous concentrés
n'attend pas l'amiral de gaulle et les
attentions corte moi je suis prête eu
avec moi je suis prêt on voit le pré
manceau je veux l'interprète philippe
genty glorieuses est bonne
non
ouais j'ai alors notre ambitieux nous
c'est gégé à la dimension trouvait
initialement bien le truc quoi méline mi
mai
allez créé l'écart avec des cas avec les
cards pour le blast des chapelles
patrick de carolis à 0,2
les bonbons
les bras
sept ans
leur coeur
ans
cwi
pour lundi
sans plus paquet
pas
au point bouchehr d'armand un point pour
jamel debbouze
on n'est pas star par hasard attention
fini pour le 3 tués près on y va
placé entre jamel et aubert
très bien
mme hamel c'est toi c'est un avant goût
à
alors
mairie
m
mais bel et bien comme ça fait alors
mélinée rebecca gérard darmon jamel
debbouze et amel ben ouannès voilà leur
ont été largués toi la cité où la
canalette renard attention numéro 4
révélation
allez
mais
m
sur balles
madame est conforme à ce que jamel
personne n'attend le grand rabbin sitruk
or c'est cette plainte est entre nous
alors ainsi tout en faisant toujours
blessé c'est tout le problème
ouais et dit bien attention là ça peut
changer de camp philippe corti
non
obama
je demande je demande un contrôle du rin
tout seul n'est pas très normal ça va
faire mal on répondre très vite et gagne
le tour de france derrière un donc à
personne de gagner ni deux fois jusqu'à
maintenant quand ils n'ont rien et
régulier à l'europe échoué ratant des
passes concentre elle accompagne dans
l'excitation je me concentre et nous
dirait on va te laver les veaux corti
non
m
l'amour
là
enfin
dès samedi
bravo bravo bravo encore comme les bleus
de gagner deux fois jusqu'à maintenant
c'est le thomas ils sont bien connus la
dernière série mercy john à merci merci
jamel moi je propose de recruter aussi
pour la vente et que ça fait longtemps
qu'on bon sens quand tu seras tu là je
serai de dos et tu es tu trouveras quand
même tard et revient sur ces normes
on peut essayer en baisse et shanghai
j'ai une arme
j'imagine quand je fais ça tu es de dos
et le malawi bien sûr le faire qu'est-ce
qui a fait que les mecs aurel maintient
des troupes les mecs ont droit de mettre
de l'eau clip we du yéla 50 ans ses
concepteurs ont aussi jeté sur le fait
qu entre chaussures homme extrêmement
secret sur notre attention aux animaux
et
ça va de soi donc deux fois thomas de
thoiry bravo les mecs
bravo les mecs attention continue
l'inter et je pense que c'est le moment
de rappeler les règles à cela oui jouer
aux us c'est important attention mans /
filippo portier
et
oui certes jean michel bienvenu géant
dormant
les beaux quartiers c'est gérard larrat
et on aura déjà que the dark et j'en
suis fière
là
je vous demande de vous inviter jusqu'à
présent qui a gagné deux fois thomas
bonne voie rythme et d'armand voilà pour
moment contrôler ça la france
d'aujourd'hui dans la france
d'aujourd'hui
bravo absolument chapeau nakhcha poésie
en continuant sa filmographie
andré aubert
en tout
continue match avait les mots gentils
c'est marc paquet c'est jean louis c'est
eux qui bloquent la main ses marques
donc pour le moment j'ai darmon deux
fois nomade fois la voirie deux fois et
la voile une fois le montage est ici les
images qui a rangé ses 1001 way se
consacre au corps à corps peut remettre
le morceau d'avant pour qu'il trouve un
truc
les gars n'ont même pas les mêmes
vibrant discours
on l'a perdu
b
tu
michel
tamer la mer d'amundsen on a enfin
changé de côté olympien de tous les gars
de l'équipe de france thierry oui quoi
la droite la gauche devrait se méfier la
droite revienne dangereusement d'harry
c'est bien le problème
1 à 2 105 heures de vidéos et kara
comment attention là ça va être très
facile et est un très très facile pour
un stationnement de lamu donc attention
au légendaire attention mondiaux a vu
les portes
annie cordy kahn a sauté un [ __ ] con
merde il fait ce qu'il veut à pardon dit
pardon c'est tout pardon pardon qui
marche bien alors léo la taille au c ur
un temps il a fait une connerie en
liberté surveillée et je sais c'est pas
moi je lis les idées raid en plus longue
une agence où vous savez donner à leur
banque chaabi stars danser et xavier
mardon en passe au micro mais attention
on passe au micro bankoa là c'est très
drôle mais mon clan dans la série les
banques au micro est aussi le micro
banco le 13 le 13 janvier
j'ai choisi bien oui c'est une attention
continue dernier
oui
mais je suis ta logique vandalia le trio
satanique cents à irlande l italie a tué
l'incarnation du service public pour moi
pour moi quand attention on passe au
mini banco à saubrigues le 14 ou le
restera mais n'attendez nationale
menteur
je
l'abbaye
about
je vends
ok
au début les autres disaient ouais il
est vieux et pas moins de huit heures le
zidane du plateau
énorme la tue c'est le temps 17 à thury
la 500 vient donc d'armes en une année à
3 mai linh l'a donc sévèrement pour le
moment qui est en tête de tout le monde
à l'algérie voudrait
m
tu viens
la chanson quand on est heureux et très
nombreux ont fait a entamé 2 3 ce soir
ah voilà
souplesse
trois secondes armand 3 pour thomas moi
je voulais en profiter pour demander à
l'équipe adverse de nous excuser ça
avant le désole que mon groupe se joue
alors on s'excuse platement voilà le
grand vainqueur est quand même là on
fasse maintenant je suis père dans le
chaos mais ça dit quoi
qui a dit quoi ascension le super-banco
match d'affilée beaucoup retour
les vosges le monde parle
original
m
donc c'est un point mort qui ça mes
enfants pour la france
le gérant
bon et qu'il faut tout refaire du début
non ne comprennent pas cette dernière
vous tout réorganiser je vous demande
est de sortir ces france et on verra
mais jean marie bigard calmez-vous il y
en a pris 8 ce qui arrive maintenant
c'est très très dur moi même je voulais
pas le mettre dans le blind test
béatrice a insisté je voulais pas je
voulais pas me c'est trop dur
j'écoute ma femme et je pense que j'ai
eu tort parce que je pense que le
marseillais
moi je l'aimé toujours ta cagoule qu'on
va te donne des ordres
philippe corti delight
non
oui
ah bon
des produits
george v
pas comme la menace iranienne est
arrivée le super méga bocaux de la mort
il ya près d fini fini finances à balles
réelles
le super méga bon ton de la mort
concentration présention s'effacer au
bois j'attends je suis aux ordres comme
starter jalousie chef est un clin d'oeil
sur les marques
quand j
oui la zouk et la mine d'or ici
alors maintenant on est dans le match 4
4 on est on est quatre pour d'armand 4
popmart s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
en battant dernier est ce que thomas et
d'arguments pourrait se mettre à côté
s'il vous plaît on voit même pas de
vivre pour moi les lèvres mais thomas
mais wide body jam et on se met à douter
ah les belles attentions
serge est ce que tu peux me c'est fait
c'est fait asseoir sur breton monsieur
veut l'interprète on te laisse pas des
cochons joue pas contre vous que
l'espagne et vous de me dire aux gens
pas du tout en valeur l attention
1 2
qui
les dégâts
attention attention il n'ya république
me suis rarement jamais la faute à massy
tu veux on voulait pas quoi toute
l'attention là il faut qu'on trouve un
vainqueur merde siffredi
mais rien de complet
l'arrêt des agressions
non
et ben voir voilà c'est fini
la société dans les débuts jusqu'à
maintenant genre le vert va nous faire
un cadeau formidable parce que chaque
fois que j'aurai une émission jeu mais
voilà c'est fini
on a des retraites est là ce soir pour
la première fois jean louis mame le
chanteur après